i met glendon last week he told me the
same story
i don't have any idea what you're
talking about
[Laughter]
[Applause]
who's glendon
you did a call back to a different
comedian
yeah yeah dude i want to let you know
you are officially 0 for 3. so
you have got the [ __ ] sombrero my
friend wear it that is not good
that is so good
you you know what i love the most about
that one
yeah dude i hear you man but yeah you
know what i love the most about that one
you were so confident when you said it
i thought i [ __ ] missed something i'm
like do i know glendon i'm sorry
but you were like [ __ ] london i'm
like i don't know oh hey glendon all
right
yeah
i love that dude
london
the best
you you getting into some [ __ ] glendon
all right
[Music]
what's your name dude
i don't want to take it
[Music]
why why why don't why don't you want to
tell me your name my name is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
my i have a couple just just quit life
questions for you
[Music]
my last name is works
[Applause]
okay now now i have a few questions that
i'm sure everybody also has
first of all first of all
what do you do for a living search
i sell beds
[Applause]
yo
if you had a mattress store
[Laughter]
called bj works you would sell out every
mattress
and it was just you sitting on the bed
with a smile like
[Applause]
uh guys would be like i'll take ten of
those mattresses i need ten of them
bj works is your name
and selling mattresses is your game
[Applause]
yo i mean
does is bj
short for anything
i live in kentucky
yeah
by the way that's the first thing you
said that was not surprising at all
[Laughter]
for billy jr and it's not short for
william i'm actually built you're billy
jr now now i have a grown-up question
for you
i mean
billy works is a whole less lot less
funny than bj works i'll tell you what
so
just at any point in time as a grown-up
were you ever
have you ever been like you know what i
think i think i can put pj to bed i
think i can help my ph.d
i might even just go by bill i can go by
bill i'm allowed to go by bill i'm a
[ __ ] grown man
yeah but you could put bj to the [ __ ]
bed you know what i'm saying
that would be quite a mattress sale
let's put bj's a bit
wow by the time that thought occurred to
me everyone just knew my name
yeah by the way right now bj who sells
mattresses it seems like way better
now now do you do you
tell customers that when they come in
do you oh god i hope you have a name tag
that just says bj
people
hey so yeah dude yeah all i can oh let
me tell you something
if i was going into a buy a mattress
right
and i walked into a store and i walked
up to the counter and i was like yeah
i'm
uh
i'm looking for a mattress
and the guy was like yeah i got just the
guy bj
i'd be like uh
is this this kind of place oh okay
[Applause]
oh i didn't i didn't catch that vibe
coming in all right
now can i ask
who's at the table with you b.j
your friend
tiffany
okay yeah yeah
yeah billy's a normal name too
yeah but you could call yourself
whatever [ __ ] you want
[Applause]
[Applause]
but i gotta tell you if
i sold mattresses
i'd go with bj2
it's memorable and do you ever
i'm sure you can find the right like
when a bro comes in you can you can work
it into a joke right
yeah
i usually just say and i went to
elementary and middle school with that
name
oh that's what you say oh
i'm sorry i thought there was going to
be a little more but that was okay
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]